CAMILLE JAMES: Hi, my name
is Camille James.
I'm from the family programs
team here at Google, and we're
very excited to have Kathy
Ireland with us here today.
So on behalf of talks
at Google, we'd like
to welcome you all.
We're going to watch a short
intro video before Kathy comes
to the stage.
[VIDEO PLAYBACK]
-So Dorothy, just in time
for this year's "Sports
Illustrated" swimsuit issue.
You have our interesting cover
for "Forbes" with Kathy
Ireland, who it turns out,
is a bit of a mogul.
How'd that happen?
-That's right.
When you think of Kathy Ireland,
you really still
think of the swimsuit model, the
gorgeous young girl from
the cover of the magazines.
But the truth is that in the
time since she stopped being a
swimsuit model, she's been
building a very big, very
legitimate business.
-Hi, I'm Kathy Ireland.
At Kathy Ireland Office by Bush
Furniture, we're finding
solutions for people
in business.
Our design--
-How come we don't know more
about that, though?
From what you said and what
you reported, she actually
sells more merchandise than
Martha Stewart does.
None of the same publicity
around it.
-Yeah.
She keeps it under the radar.
I mean, she said herself that
she is glad that she's been
able to build her company
under the radar.
But part of keeping it under
the radar means that she's
selling some things that a lot
of people don't think about.
She sells flooring.
There's about $400 million in
replacement windows that are
sold that are Kathy Ireland
replacement windows.
-People buy Kathy Ireland
replacement windows?
-Yeah.
I mean, who knew what a
replacement window was?
-Looking in this vignette,
lightning, upholstery, window
treatments, rugs, and more is
all available from our Kathy
Ireland collections.
-But on top of that, she also
has a big bridal business.
She has villas in Hawaii and in
Los Angeles where you can
go and have a wedding.
She does wedding dresses.
She has tableware.
She has jewelry.
I mean, almost anything you
can think of around that,
there's a Kathy Ireland branded
product that you could
use in your wedding.
-So how big is this business?
You spent some time with the
numbers, and I know that
they're a little opaque
about them.
-Yeah.
They don't love to talk about
the numbers over at Kathy
Ireland Worldwide.
It's a private company.
I mean, that's their right.
But we did crunch the numbers.
-And how much of that
does she own?
-She owns 100% of the company.
-So Kathy Ireland, while not a
billionaire, and probably not
any time soon, in terms of
top earners in and around
Hollywood, how is she doing?
-At "Forbes" here, we
look at people who
earn billions of dollars.
So by some of our rich list
people it's not so big.
But when you look at the
Hollywood world, they don't
earn hundreds of millions
of dollars, generally.
So for her to be worth even half
a billion dollars is an
impressive achievement.
-So how did that happen?
-It started with a
line of socks.
Someone came to her and
said, would you
model a line of socks?
This was in around 1993.
She was coming to the end
of her modeling career.
She said, you know what?
I don't want to model your
socks, I want to go into
business with you.
I want these to be Kathy Ireland
socks, and I want to
have some ownership
in this company.
From there they moved into
sportswear, eventually swimsuits.
She was very specific she did
not want to start with
swimsuits because her feeling
was, of course people are
going to buy swimsuits
with my name on them.
Will they buy stocks?
If they can buy socks, then I
see that there's going to be a
legitimate business here.
-So how do we get to replacement
windows?
-She had a line of clothing
at Kmart for a long time.
She came to the realization that
home goods are a little
more stable.
They don't change as often.
You could start to make
inroads in there.
Her first thing that she did
in home goods was floors.
Very unsexy.
But her feeling was we started
with socks as the foundation
for our clothing line, we'll
start with floors as the
foundation for our
home goods line.
And from there it grew, And she
realized that in this very
unsexy business of furniture,
there were no brands.
And if something says Kathy
Ireland, it's just that little
thing that makes people
buying furniture
say, oh, Kathy Ireland.
I associate that
with something.
With some kind of glamor or some
kind of assurance more
than this name that I've
never heard of.
So maybe I'll get the Kathy
Ireland one instead.
The brand is powerful in the
furniture business, which most
people don't know much about.
-So you go up, you visit
her at her house.
You sit-in on a business meeting
and something catches
your eye there?
-Yes.
I was sitting in her living room
and there's an Oscar in
her living room.
-As far as we know, we've never
seen her in something
Oscar worthy.
-No.
I mean, she certainly has
had an acting career.
But she herself will admit
that she was not the best
actress out there.
It turns out the Oscar was a
gift from Elizabeth Taylor.
And it turns out that Elizabeth
Taylor and Kathy
Ireland were very, very close.
When Kathy Ireland talks about
Elizabeth Taylor, she talks
about her in the
present tense.
She can't talk about her as
somebody who's passed.
That's how close she
was in life.
She learned a lot about jewelry
from Elizabeth Taylor.
Elizabeth Taylor, of course, had
this mammoth, $50 million,
maybe, collection worth of
jewelry, and she taught Kathy
Ireland to look at jewelery.
Kathy built herself up her
own collection of jewelry
-And her people say
it's worth?
-They say it's estimated at
maybe around $25 million.
But it's not kept in her home.
It's kept in a safe
in Los Angeles.
And they felt it was
very important that
I point that out.
The more you talk to Kathy
island, the more sort of
strange details start to come
out about her and her company.
She was very influenced
by Warren Buffett.
So she has furniture at the
Nebraska Furniture Mart, which
is owned by Berkshire
Hathaway.
She does flooring with Shaw
Furniture, which is also owned
by Berkshire Hathaway.
She really looks up to Warren
Buffett as somebody who she
wants to emulate.
And in fact, her company is
becoming a wide conglomerate
of lots of different kinds of
businesses, almost in the same
sort of way that Berkshire
Hathaway is, but at a much
lower valuation.
[END VIDEO PLAYBACK]
CAMILLE JAMES: Now,
for a quick intro.
Launched in 1993, Kathy Ireland
Worldwide is the 25th
most popular,
powerfully-licensed brand in
the world, ranking higher than
Martha Stewart, Tommy Bahama,
and Polo Ralph Lauren.
As chair, CEO, and chief
designer of an entity that is
now $2 billion--
I'm sorry, now a $2 billion
industry according to
"Forbes," which sells over
45,000 products in over 50,000
retail stores in 50 countries.
No wonder "Forbes" has named
Kathy a Super Mogul and the
first lady of flyover country.
Fairchild Publications named
her one of the 50 Most
Influential People in Fashion.
Kathy resides in Southern
California with her husband
Greg and their three
children--
Eric, Lily, and Chloe--
balancing her responsibilities
as a wife, a mother, a
philanthropist, and
an entrepreneur.
So ladies and gentlemen and
Googlers, welcome Kathy.
[APPLAUSE]
KATHY IRELAND: Thank
you, Camille.
CAMILLE JAMES: Thank you.
KATHY IRELAND: Thank
you, Camille.
Hello, everybody.
It's so great to be here
At Googleplex.
This place is incredible.
And being here in beautiful
Mountain View, it makes me
very mindful we are in the
heartland of great leaders.
And those great leaders include
your very own Sergey
Brin, Larry Page,
Eric Schmidt.
And they're great leaders
because they lead an
incredible team.
And that's all of you.
There is incredible awareness
about Google, about this team,
about all of you.
If people are aware of me,
it's usually fragmented.
If you didn't blink, you might
have caught my very brief
twirl on "Dancing with
the Stars" before
I got the big boot.
I'm looking around here.
Maybe your parents might
remember me as that model
person from back in
the last century.
And you have incredible people
come and speak with you.
So when you found out you got
me, it's likely that some of
you might have thought,
Kathy Ireland?
Oh, come on.
What's she going to do today?
Dig up as old pose and
teach it to us?
Well, OK.
If you're interested,
all right.
After a really big meal-- and
you guys have great food at
this facility--
turns sideways.
Suck it in.
Twist at the torso,
and you create the
illusion of a waistline.
It's all an illusion.
And then, after indulging in
desserts, which I love to do,
get yourself a really good
photo retoucher.
Mine is a woman named
Paulinda.
Today with Photoshop, anything
can be done.
It is wonderful.
Those are my biggest secrets
of modeling.
You can see with that pose,
I was OK as a model.
Certainly, not super.
Always knew I belonged on the
other side of the lens.
Design and business
were my passions.
And I was more interested in
designing the red carpet than
walking it.
The truly supermodels who worked
in that industry when I
did included Cindy, Cheryl,
Christie, Naomi, Heidi, Tyra.
These supermodels were and
continue to be seen and heard
everywhere.
I was occasionally seen,
very rarely heard.
Yes, my job description
was shut up and pose.
When I had the rare occasion to
speak, a critic said that I
had a voice that could
kill small animals.
Not a real confidence builder.
Criticism can be a gift,
sometimes wrapped in a really
nasty package.
And in order to discern if it's
noise that needs to be
tossed away, turned off, or if
there's something we can learn
from it, we've got to open it.
And I had to admit.
I was 25 years old.
I couldn't even order a pizza.
I had a really high voice and
they thought I was a kid
making a prank phone call.
So that criticism was a fork
in the road for me.
It forced me to decide if I
would let the cruelty of those
remarks forever silence me or
if, despite the criticism, I
would speak out on issues
of importance.
And I'm so happy to be
here with you today.
It's mind boggling to be here.
We had a fantastic tour today.
I mean, everybody has been so
kind, from Cliff to Mike,
Matt, Gobi, Abigail.
Just amazing.
And your history, it's
so inspiring.
From 1842 when this was a
Mexican land grant divided
into Mountain View
and in Sunnyvale.
And to think, I'm excited with
your stewardship what the next
5 years, 10 years, 50 years
are going to look like.
We know that this town, its
growth was attributed to
agriculture.
And those seeds, they continue
to germinate, to flourish.
But instead of turning into
plants, those seeds are the
ideas that are flourishing
and that are
serving people globally.
And for that, we thank you.
You are truly amazing.
And it's exciting what's
happening.
I'm going to share with you just
a little bit about our
family dynamic, so you'll
understand why modeling didn't
rank high--
the achievement level.
My husband, as well as being an
emergency room physician,
is a commercial fisherman.
When he's not saving lives,
he's killing lobster.
Mom worked as a nurse.
My dad worked with labor
relations with the farm worker
Cesar Chavez.
So great people.
My husband would come home from
work and talk about a
life he helped save.
And I'd come home and it's
like, well, I came
up with a new pose.
And you all saw it.
So you know what I mean.
It was a really pathetic
time in my life.
I mean, I'm telling you, I had
a full-on pity party-- the
cake, ice cream, hat,
the whole works.
I had the arrogance to expect
that I ought to receive all of
my fulfillment from my work when
all I had to do was open
my eyes and extend my arms.
There are needs all around.
And with Google.org, you
understand that.
And we're all so grateful for
the incredible work that you
do, everything for working to
eradicate poverty, to serve
people through education.
What you do to help
the environment--
amazing.
There is so, so much that we
need to learn from you.
And something that I had to
learn during that time was to
get over my hubris and
to learn to be a
servant and a student.
I love to learn.
Being mentored and mentoring,
those are passions of mine.
And through Google, we can be
mentored by people in the
present, the past instantly.
In the video, I talked about
Elizabeth Taylor.
If you Google Elizabeth Taylor,
you'll learn about her
legendary film career.
You'll see gorgeous images.
You'll learn about her
work with HIV/AIDS.
What cannot be contained, even
in the pages of Google, is her
enormous heart.
And what a privilege to be
mentored by this woman in the
'80s when the AIDS epidemic
was just reaching us.
She was frustrated that so
little was being done.
Why isn't anybody
doing anything?
One day she looked in
the mirror and she
said, wait a minute.
I'm somebody and I
can do something.
When she called her friends
to ask for help,
they hung up on her.
She received death threats.
Her business associates pleaded
with her to just let
this thing alone.
She didn't let any
of that stop her.
She boldly moved forward and
established the Elizabeth
Taylor HIV/AIDS Foundation
and amFAR.
And there is so much that she
did that we will never know
because some of it wasn't
even legal.
But she wouldn't let
that stop her.
And she continues to be the
Joan of Arc of AIDS.
And her work continues
from heaven today.
Being mentored is powerful.
And as we get that opportunity,
then to give back
and to mentor, to be able to
share with others a little bit
about our journey, that
is a joy for me.
Most of my lessons I've
learned the hard way.
I look at failure
as education.
In that respect, I'm
very well educated.
And I hope there's something
from our journey that can
benefit yours as well.
Today, many women are
called mompreneurs.
Are there any moms here today?
Anybody out here?
Oh, you, too?
Yes.
How many kids do you have?
AUDIENCE: Two.
KATHY IRELAND: Two.
And what about you?
AUDIENCE: Two.
KATHY IRELAND: Two.
And what are their ages?
AUDIENCE: Five and eight.
KATHY IRELAND: Five and eight.
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE].
KATHY IRELAND: And you never
stop being a mom.
I mean, it goes on and on.
When I was a kid, something that
frustrated me is when--
my mom's, when her career was
being a mom, that people would
say, well, you don't work.
I was like, what?
Are you kidding me, that's the
hardest job in the world.
And all moms work whether
we get paid or not.
I can't think of anything more
challenging or important than
raising children.
And I think sadly in our
society, because a paycheck
isn't attached, that the
career of being a mom
oftentimes doesn't receive the
empathy and the respect that
it deserves.
But I am so happy to be a
mompreneur and to share with
you our journey from the beach
to the board room and beyond.
Something I love about
Googleplex is you are
passionate people.
And I love that 20%
of your time is
devoted to your passions.
And out of those, of that time,
the innovations are just
astounding.
I mean, from Gmail, all of it.
It's incredible.
And my passion have always
been design and business.
My first job was a combination
of both.
I was four years old, sold
painted rocks from my wagon
with my sister Mary.
Mary being three years older,
designs more sophisticated,
sold hers for a dime.
I sold mine for a nickel.
And even at that reduced rate,
I did really well.
I learned at a young age
that my customers
appreciate a good value.
And I've got to admit, I was
tempted to market my rocks,
buy two of mine for
one of Mary's.
But I realized that would
be unfair competition.
And it's much more fun to
celebrate our differences and
to work in partnership
together.
From there, when I was about
seven, started designing
handbags and jewelry to
coordinate with the 1970s
halter dresses that my mom sewed
from our home and we
sold at beach fairs.
My first serious job, though,
was a paper route.
11 years old and my dad kind of
gently shoves a newspaper
under my nose with an ad that
read newspaper carrier wanted.
Are you the boy for the job?
So dad knew what kind of
reaction that was going
to get out of me.
I wrote to the newspaper and I
said, no, I'm not the boy for
the job, I'm the girl
for the job.
I can do this route just
as well as any boy.
I deserve a chance.
First day, New Year's day,
papers are extra thick and I'm
a really scrawny 11-year-old
thinking, what have I gotten
myself into?
I'm peddling up this really
steep hill and I notice this
man standing at the end
of his driveway.
And as I got closer, it was
very apparent that he was
upset about something.
The veins were popping
out of his neck.
His face was beet red.
And as I handed him his paper,
he began yelling at me.
What are you doing here?
This is a boy's job.
You have no business
being here.
You are never going to last.
And I didn't let
him see me cry.
But to this day, I'm really
grateful to that man.
There were a lot of days
I wanted to quit.
I wouldn't give him
that satisfaction.
And I couldn't because
what about the girls
coming up behind me?
And what would that say to the
person who wrote that ad that
I rejected in the first place?
And I'm curious, anybody here
at any point in your life,
have you ever been discriminated
against?
You're too young?
You're too old?
You're too this color?
Too that size?
Yeah.
All right, some of you.
It stinks.
It really, really stinks.
And I encourage you
not to ever let
anyone else define you.
Here at Google, you think
outside the box.
And in order to think outside
the box, you can never allow
anyone to put you in a box.
I'm too odd-shaped.
I don't fit in anybody's box.
And I'm grateful for the lessons
that I learned on that
paper route.
My dad taught me, Kathy,
give 110%.
If the customer expects the
paper on the driveway, you put
it on the front porch.
And that was the foundation of
my learning to under promise
and over deliver.
And more than 30 years
later, still the girl
with a paper route.
Modeling was not part
of the plan.
Ended up being a great
education.
Entire time I worked in that
industry, I was trying and
failing at businesses before
we started our brand in '93
from my kitchen table with
a single pair of socks.
Now, when I modeled,
people teased me.
They said, you're so cheap.
Why don't you buy some better
clothes or drive a nicer car?
At least pay for
valet parking.
I was investing in people.
The way people are treated is
far more important than any
profit margin.
And I love sports.
I love the idea of working
towards a common goal.
And we have a wonderfully
diverse team.
And I know that you do
as well, at Google.
And I love that.
If everybody were just like
us, it would be so boring.
And we have some great debate.
And that's awesome.
And I love it.
It keeps us growing
and thinking.
I know my strengths, and I'm
very well aware of my
weaknesses.
I believe in always learning
new things, always growing.
Yet, to be efficient, to
focus, to develop those
strengths and work with people
who are strong in areas where
we are not.
So someone with a great eye who
would become our creative
director, an art director,
someone with strengths in
production and marketing,
a vision strategist.
And I was actually offered
the opportunity to model
this pair of socks.
Not quite as glamorous
as it sounds.
It was a really tiny budget,
no exotic locations, and no
much needed photo retoucher.
But it was a job.
And it was at a time when not
a lot of job offers were
coming my way.
Still, I felt if I didn't close
the door on that chapter
of my life, I might
not live my dream
of design and business.
And I liked the people.
And as you here know,
life and business,
it's all about people.
It's about relationships.
And I thought this would
be a great place
to start our brand.
Some say it's counterintuitive,
but for me
it made perfect sense.
If women embrace something as
basic as a pair of socks, what
could our team bring as far as
innovation, design, fashion?
If they embrace that, we might
be onto something.
So the work began.
We conducted family-based focus
groups, surprise factory
inspections.
You learn a lot when you
show up unannounced.
And it's a practice
we continue today.
Thoroughly research these
potential new partners.
Took out the first in
a series of loans.
And John Carrasco, our genius
creative director, he and I
loaded up our backpacks.
We hit the road and presented
our socks to retailers.
And the doors slammed
in our faces.
You're not good enough.
Love the socks, but
who needs you?
You can't start a brand
with a pair of socks.
It's never been done.
As you all know, it's never been
done does not mean that
it can't be done.
That's noise.
And in order to succeed in life
and in business, we have
to turn off that noise so we
can move forward with the
plans for our life.
One of the greatest gifts of
that long ago modeling
career-- and I didn't realize
it at the time--
it was all the rejection.
Because when people said no and
slammed doors, it didn't
destroy me.
I was used to it.
It was OK.
It's like, OK, at least
we're talking.
We'll come back tomorrow.
Maybe your circumstances
will have changed.
Or maybe you'll be
in a better mood.
And that gift of rejection, it
really leads to perseverance.
And it doesn't feel like it at
the time, but please, when
you're facing rejection, know
that it can be a beautiful
gift later on.
In the early days of our brand,
there were times when
we slept in airports in an
effort to save money.
And some people think
of sleeping in an
airport as a big deal.
It's not a big deal.
What ever material things we
have to give up to live our
dream, it's not a sacrifice.
It's a bold investment.
And that bold investment made it
possible for us to sell our
100 millionth pair of socks.
In the early days, we sold our
socks in a handful of sporting
good stores, including
Big Five.
Then a major mass retailer
started carrying our socks.
And one day, CEO calls me in
to inform me that the socks
are a blow out.
And we had just had
our first baby in
diapers, so blowout had--
you moms know, had a really
different meaning.
But he assured me,
no, this is OK.
It's a good thing.
In fact, they asked for
exclusivity at their channel
of distribution.
And our brand grew.
It grew to include a complete
line of apparel and
accessories.
As our brand grew, so
did our spending.
Bigger, fancier office spaces
than we truly needed.
Airport sleepovers, those
days were long gone.
But our banks, our financial
advisers, assured us that our
sending was far below the norm
for a company of our size.
Besides, we had a contract that
guaranteed security for
years to come.
Then one day, I get
a phone call.
A little more than surprising.
It seems that this retailer was
having a few challenges.
Next?
A crashing avalanche
of reality.
This retailer was filing
bankruptcy.
What?
A $40 billion giant bankrupt?
No way.
Way.
Next, I get a call from the
bank to set up a lunch for
what they politely referred
to as the situation.
And I had enjoyed lunch with a
bank on several occasions,
always sharing our business
plan, keeping them up to date.
But this time was
very different.
This time it was crystal
clear that I was going
to pick up the check.
With this retailer underwater,
our bank was reacting to
change instantly.
Not going to spend another
dime on them.
And while reaching for the
credit card, one of the kind,
fatherly bankers smiled and
said, you know, you and your
partners are personally
responsible
for the entire liability.
If this doesn't work out, we can
take away all your homes.
His smile was chilling.
I should have known better.
Particularly since we had 37
team members with families on
our payroll, it was the largest
bankruptcy in retail history.
And my heart still breaks for
the thousands of people who
lost their jobs, insurance,
benefits, stock.
But today with new management,
that retailer is a healthier
company, and we are, too.
But those days were
pretty grim.
We scrambled and scurried
24/7 days.
And we still do that.
And it makes me think of what
you all do at Google.
When I look around--
and some people talk
about these days of
being days of challenge.
Clearly, you see them as
days of opportunity.
When businesses are closing, how
life-changing that people
can go to Google.
They can get connected
with others
around the world instantly.
You bring opportunities and
you make it a reality.
And that is enormous.
Before the bankruptcy, our
internal plan was to move to
the independent channel
of distribution.
We felt that being dependent
upon one retailer was not a
solution for our customer
or our team.
The bankruptcy slowed
our clock.
I'll never walk away from
anyone during their most
difficult time.
When it was clear they were
going to be healthy, we
implemented that plan.
Again, people said
it's impossible.
You can't start at
mass and go up.
It's never been done.
For years we were able
to operate our
business under the radar.
And as a private person owning a
private company, that suited
me just fine.
One of the reasons we were able
to be beneath the radar
is because typically independent
retailers don't
have large ad budgets.
So while others were buying
awareness, we were building
relationships one at a time.
And that's what you do.
You connect people.
And you help build those
relationships.
And that's exciting and
that's powerful.
And bringing your technology
to our retail partners, to
family businesses that have been
around for generations
that will not survive without
it, that is exciting.
And I thank you for that.
"Forbes" outed our business
for its growth.
And others in the media
commented as well.
And that forced me out of my
shy and selfish shell of
quietness to connect and
share with others.
And as I mature, I realize that
it is so not about me.
And that my comfort is
absolutely irrelevant when
there are needs everywhere.
And I'm so grateful for what all
of you do because you make
it possible for us to fulfill
our personal, our
professional, and our
philanthropic goals.
And you make it possible for
us to do this instantly.
So thank you for that.
Sometimes people ask us,
what are your secrets?
And to us, they're
pretty simple.
Consider others as more
important than yourself.
Never stop auditioning.
Bring value.
Be creative.
Be honest.
Be of service.
I love your non-official mission
of don't be evil.
I love that.
It speaks volumes of you.
And I think something that we
share in common as your
company is about connecting and
that's so much of what we
do as well, and we've
got to get ourselves
in order to do that.
We can't get in our own way.
We all have these epiphanies at
different moments in life.
I prefer to think of them
as breakthroughs, those
crystalline moments when
life just hits us.
And we either fall apart,
collapse and break down, or we
break the bonds that seek to
destroy and defeat us.
We get back up and
we break through.
Some personal examples of
breakthroughs in my life
include breaking through health
challenges, an accident
that tore my nose from my face,
smashed my teeth, left
me unconscious, and my
face unrecognizable.
My physician husband fearing
I'd be brain dead.
A disaster at sea that nearly
took my husband's life.
I spoke to you about that brush
with bankruptcy from our
then only retail partner.
The loss of loved ones.
A miscarriage that our
family still mourns.
A life-changing misdiagnosis
and a diagnosis of down
syndrome for the youngest member
of our extended family.
Each one of you here have or is
currently facing equal or
far greater crises.
And yet, you are here.
And you are a shining example
that you don't break down, you
break through.
And you inspire.
You encourage.
In spending time here on this
campus today, getting to see
how you work, it feels
like a family.
And I love that.
And getting to talk with some of
you, it's been an exciting
experience.
Because each one of us,
we are our own brand.
And you might be thinking,
she's crazy.
She's talking about her
brand, and then she's
saying I'm a brand.
I'm not a brand.
I'm a person.
Yes, we're people.
And we are brands.
And every experience with us is
a lasting brand impression.
The question is, what kind
of a brand are we?
Are we innovative, creative?
Are we solution-oriented?
Do we get along well
with others?
Do we consider showing up five
minutes early being on time or
are we perpetually late?
Are we complicated and cranky?
Do we bring our drama with
us everywhere we go?
And we are all works
in progress.
Unfortunately, every day we
get to make the choice if
we're going to break down
or break through.
And brands succeed because
they simplify
the selection process.
They build upon an existing
relationship.
Will a brand or a service
succeed if the product or
service is inferior?
Absolutely not.
The quickest way to destroy
any brand is poor quality
merchandise or service.
Generally speaking, men
will buy products
and women join brands.
There's that loyalty,
that relationship.
And when there is a product of
comparable or lesser price
versus a well-branded product,
the well-branded
product will succeed.
And this is particularly true
during economic uncertainties
and societal changes.
Women shop where they have that
trusted relationship.
We've got to earn that trust.
And we've got to get it right.
But building that
relationship.
And again, that's what
you at Google do.
You build relationships, and you
connect us, and you make
it possible.
And that is powerful.
Google is an iconic brand.
Other examples of
iconic brands--
Disney, Coca-Cola, Nike.
Iconic brands are known as much
for how they make us feel
as for what they do.
Iconic brands trade in the
world of emotion where
measurements cannot apply.
And the consistency
is so important.
Your bold, beautiful
Google logo, that
is recognized worldwide.
And it's powerful.
And we know what we're getting
when we go to Google.
When we're drinking our
Starbucks coffee, if that
circular logo were suddenly
dropped to the bottom with no
notice, we wouldn't trust
what we were drinking.
So with our marketing, with our
branding, with ourselves
it's so important that we are
consistent with who we are and
what we're all about.
And I love your name--
Google.
It's awesome.
When our youngest child Chloe
was in kindergarten, she came
home from school one day and
she told me she loved me
Googleplex.
And I just love that.
I love it.
And before I close, I've got
to shout out to the women.
Not to neglect the guys.
Love the guys.
And girls, we have so much
to learn from the guys.
We really do.
You are really good
at delegating.
And when you have your
priorities, you're good at
putting yourselves on it.
And we need to learn
from that.
We just go to this guilt thing
if we try to spend any time to
take care of ourselves.
Frequently, women will ask
me, how do you do it all?
And my answer is, I don't.
And oftentimes, I do
it really badly.
I was 40 years old before
I learned that no
was a complete sentence.
No thank you was better,
but no works.
It's OK.
And oftentimes, we've got to
say no to good things in an
effort to be able to say
yes to great things.
When I flew out last night to
come be with you today, the
flight attendant said, in case
of emergency, put on your own
oxygen mask first, and then take
care of those around you.
And it made me think, what
if we did that in a
prophylactic way?
And I had the privilege of
speaking at a conference that
included some amazing women--
Dr. Maya Angelou, Barbara
Walters--
and the topic came up, can
women have it all?
And Barbara Walters said,
no, I don't believe
women can have it all.
And respectfully, I disagree.
I think we can have it all,
but not all at once.
Our lives come in seasons.
And at each season of our
life, we've got to
prioritize our time.
For me, it's my faith, family,
and then being of service
through our work.
And the minute those priorities
are out of order,
I'm a disaster.
Coping skills are
out the window.
Stress is unmanageable.
I'm floundering around on the
floor trying to get from point
A to point B. It just
doesn't work.
What I love about Google is
I see that there's so much
protection for you.
I see the opportunities here.
I see the child care.
And just making it
all possible.
And that is fantastic.
And I encourage everyone, if you
haven't already, to think
about, what are your values?
What's important to you?
And it's so important that you
have conviction for your
values to really know why you
value what you value.
And to put boundaries in place
to protect them because they
will be challenged.
In our business, something that
we do, we're constantly
working with new people,
new relationships.
And we go through our
legal process.
We get everything
out in the open.
Potential concerns
all in writing.
Everything is signed.
And then we take those
contracts, we put them away in
the drawer, and we start
treating one
another like family.
I never had a family business.
But today, we have a
business family.
And I believe that when
you treat your family
members the way you--
when you treat your business
family the way you would want
your family members to be
treated, there's no limit to
what we can accomplish
together.
And you were certainly a family
here at Googleplex.
And there is no limit to what
you will accomplish.
And in speaking of family, just
a shout out to some of
our team members--
Selena, Miles, and Chris.
And Christopher Spencer, who
is our Google expert--
and he keeps our business
all things Google.
Just so wonderful.
We're so grateful for that.
You're an amazing family.
And I imagine that it's going
to take a few hundred years
for you to fully realize the
return on your investment in
the Klingon interface.
You guys are incredible.
And you make me realize that
there are no limits.
I'm encouraged and inspired
by all of you.
And in closing, I'm going to
share with you something--
it's not my own, but I believe
it to be true.
I've learned that all that you
give is all that you get.
So give it all you've got.
Here's to life and every
joy it brings.
Here's to life and dreamers
and their dreams.
May all your storms
be weathered.
May all that's good
get better.
Here's to life.
Here's to love.
Here's to each and
every one of you.
Thank you, and God bless you.
[APPLAUSE]
KATHY IRELAND: You're
so sweet.
Thank you.
Does anybody have
any questions?
AUDIENCE: Are there businesses
that you've entered and then
had to shut down later?
Or ones that you decided
not to enter?
For example, there's, as far
as I know, no such thing as
Kathy Ireland Fine China.
KATHY IRELAND: I'm sorry, you
said as far as you know, there
is Kathy Ireland Fine China?
AUDIENCE: There is not.
KATHY IRELAND: Oh.
Yes, coming.
And what is your name?
AUDIENCE: Neil.
KATHY IRELAND: Neil.
Neil, thank you for that.
Kathy Ireland Home by Gorham.
It's coming out.
No, it's been in development.
Yes.
One of the things that really
helps us is our mission.
We have it in bold letters, in
English and in Spanish in our
headquarters.
Sometimes people think our team
is a cult because we're
confidently reiterating it.
Most of us, we've been together
over 20 years.
Our mission began with finding
solutions for families,
especially busy moms.
We've expanded to finding
solutions for people in love
and finding solutions for
people in business.
So when a team member has an
idea for a new product, we go
to that mission.
OK, it's a great idea, but
where's the solution?
How does it maker
her day better?
She's going through life
and it is hard.
When I became a mom for
the first time, a
shower became a luxury.
And going to the store.
Even how we choose our retail
partners is critical.
She's got car seats, diapers,
temper tantrums.
She makes it out the driveway,
that's a victory in itself.
So we've got to make sure
it's a good shopping
experience for her.
And it's time.
It's a getting to know
you process.
When all the other elements
are in place, we also have
four promises for
all the products
we design and market--
fashion, quality, value,
and safety.
They have to be in place.
You asked if we ever had to walk
away from relationships?
Yes, sadly.
We do our homework as
much as we can, but
things in life happen.
There was a partner who felt
that because they were in the
legal limits of safety
that it was OK.
But they were not at the highest
standard of legal
limits for safety.
And with that mission statement,
serving families,
safety being one of our core
promises, we walked away for
millions of dollars.
We gave our banks
heart attacks.
It's one of the reasons I love
having a private company.
Because it allows us the
freedom to do that.
But the getting to know your
process is critical.
Kicking the tires.
And we invite people to kick
the tires with us.
We try to be as transparent
as possible.
Find out everything you can do
about us, so we can-- we look
at it as a marriage, a long-time
relationship.
That's what we're looking for.
AUDIENCE: Thanks.
KATHY IRELAND: Thank
you, Neil.
AUDIENCE: Hi, my
name is Albert.
Just started two weeks ago.
This is a perk that they didn't
tell me of beforehand.
KATHY IRELAND: You're
a Noogler?
AUDIENCE: Exactly.
My question to you is, so you
had an extremely successful
supermodel career.
So you had an extremely
successful supermodel career
that you could have
easily said at the
end of it, I'm done.
I've had a wonderful career,
and kind of sailed off into
the sunset.
What made you want to start
your own business?
What gave you that push
to say, this isn't
enough, I want more?
KATHY IRELAND: The pity party
that I mentioned.
allowed me to take my eyes off
myself and look around.
And see that it wasn't just
about me and having
my own needs met.
But there were so many
opportunities.
And that was a critical turning
point in my life.
I entered the modeling
industry as a
business person already.
I really thought it wasn't
part of my plan.
I thought I might be able to
save some money for college or
to start a business.
The reason it went on so long is
because I failed at so many
other businesses.
It took me a long time
to get started.
So it was always a
passion of mine.
And one of the things I learned
the hard way is when
you have a business, you've got
to be passionate about it.
And then, it's not work.
I don't imagine--
I can't imagine ever retiring.
I imagine shifting and changing
focus here and there,
being true to those
priorities.
As we talk about moving beyond,
I see my pivot just
going to honor those
priorities.
And I see what you all do as
Google as a huge facilitator
to make those dreams
a reality.
AUDIENCE: Thanks.
KATHY IRELAND: Thank you.
AUDIENCE: I guess my question
kind of had to do with women
in the workplace and how you
would approach that.
Before I came to Google, I was
working at a law firm and we
handled a lot of gender
discrimination cases
on behalf of women.
And it seemed to me that
something that happened quite
often, especially for younger
women, was that they kind of
fell into the stereotype of
being the pretty young thing
around the office.
And I was just wondering you,
as a business woman, did you
feel like beauty was something
that was an obstacle for you
to go past for people to take
you seriously, or did you feel
more like it was something that
you could capitalize upon
to improve upon your business?
KATHY IRELAND: Thank you.
And while you're sweet to
put me in that category.
But I often still feel that
many times if I were--
because women will say to me,
well, it's easy for you.
You had this modeling
background, so it gets you a
foot in the door.
I really believe that if I would
show up at a business
meeting with my business plan
and my sketches in hand, my
ideas as a CEO would be taken
seriously much more quickly
than having that baggage of that
perception from that long
ago career.
And what a woman who doesn't
have that has,
she has a clean slate.
So she gets to invent her
brand however she wants.
And that is the gift.
And as far as your question
about what's expected in the
workplace, how women
are perceived, I
continue to see it.
One of my first in the
home industry--
I went to a meeting
of salespeople.
And it was all guys.
I was like, is there a meeting
or where's all the women?
They didn't have any women.
I was like. you guys, who's
buying the furniture?
Can we have a little balance?
And it takes time.
I just encourage women to fight
against that, to persevere.
And with love, we can teach.
And it's powerful.
I'm very rebellious.
And I think I encourage
people to rebel
against negative things.
And to be strong.
There's so many things we
need to rebel against.
But for years, I only wore like
full-on business suits
because I wanted to be
taken seriously.
And it was Elizabeth Taylor
who gave me so much grief.
She just said, you know what?
You don't need to do that.
Wear what you want to
wear and let them
deal with their stuff.
You be true to yourself.
And if you feel like wearing
the pantsuit, fine.
But don't feel like--
I think I was allowing other
people to shape me.
And we just be true
to who we are.
And we do our best.
And it becomes their
problem, not ours.
AUDIENCE: Thanks.
KATHY IRELAND: Thank you.
AUDIENCE: Hey, Kathy.
I just wanted to thank you once
again for coming out here
and talking to all of us.
I had a quick question about
your business side, and how
you talked about you had
a family business.
And kind of more of a business
family and whatnot.
If you ever thought about going
public or kind of your
views on that?
Because I know you brought up
how you're private right now
and you're very happy with the
structure of that, just kind
of want to hear your
two cents.
KATHY IRELAND: I cannot
imagine going public.
I wouldn't go public
in a titular sense.
I've been accused of being
a control freak.
But I'm passionate
about what we do.
Every area.
And so I can't imagine
giving that up.
Would we ever work with
public companies?
Yes.
I mean, there's ways
of doing that.
But for our company, I
enjoy the privacy.
If we want to give our banks
heart attacks and give away
more than what we--
we can do that.
We have that luxury.
I mean, just this week, we've
had team members--
one of our dear team members,
his father died.
And he needs to go away
and be with family.
And I see how Google--
from what I see, how everyone is
treated, I really love it.
I mean, I don't know
everything.
But it just seems like a
really great company.
You're taken care of.
But in this point in time,
I love the privacy.
Wall Street looks for a really
quick return, and that
frightens me.
Because when we're building
relationships,
we're looking long-term.
I don't know how to
make a quick buck.
When people do that--
we've never done it.
It's built over time.
And it's by cultivating those
relationships, so I don't
think I would be very good
at a public company.
But thank you.
AUDIENCE: Awesome.
Thank you.
KATHY IRELAND: Thank you.
Anybody else, any questions?
Thank you all so much
for coming out.
It was really great to spend
this time with you.
Thank you.
[APPLAUSE]